[Music]
hello
and welcome to the next
talk of today um it's about
observability actually so
the talk was announced open metrics open
telemetry open
tracing i already messed up the terms uh
are we there yet
i have a nickname for it it's called
trace trace
so let me switch to the slides now
and
so first of all i want to touch
uh about uh on upon topic why we need
to measure things so um
you could imagine that when you talk
about slam tree we talk about
open metrics and stuff uh it's it's all
about uh
it's all about measurements so why do we
need to measure
um a lot of people entered the world of
microservices
kind of it took us by the storm a few
years back
and now it becomes more like a
mainstream it's it's pretty normal so
people
do mic services uh however
what's my experience what i've done
before uh
working in different companies that uh
we were missing important points
essentially when we distributed our
system sometimes
we got into situations when we felt like
we lost control
why this happens because well i think
mainly because we forgot about
uh observing a single analytic
application is much easier
than observing uh plateau or
microservices
that are hosted on different virtual
machines now we host things in token
kubernetes and stuff like that
so um first of all
basically despite all this bullet points
i can
happily keep them you need to know about
the problems
before your users do and this is
essentially why we need to why we need
to measure things
uh it's the worst thing that could ever
happen is that when you
deploy something in production
preferably on friday night because of
course you want to go
and drive to the mountains and then in
the middle of your drive or the next
night
someone calls you and says that's
nothing works
and the worst thing that can happen is
the customer goes in
so another thing is that i mentioned
in one of the bullet points is that
measuring the usage of
certain things like click on the page
and
certain number of execution of certain
commands
maybe some queries and api calls can
actually
help you finding out that something
needs to be sunset because
it doesn't work supporting anymore
because nobody uses it it's very helpful
thing to do
my click is not going well
let me just do it old-fashioned way
sorry about the glitch um so how do we
measure um
we have um fortunately the industry
developed a number of tools to
to use for measurements and we have a
lot of vendors that offer decent tools
that are either hosted basically they're
all
cloud-based software as a service
i personally used new relic a long time
ago and
now i use more datadog there are
every cloud provider has their own tools
that help people
that work with that particular cloud to
observe things
but of course when you go that way
it becomes harder to for example go
multi-cloud
or entirely migrate to another cloud
however there are ways to do that in a
vendor agnostic way
and today
we have for measurements in particularly
um for for metrics we have
uh openmetrics as more or less a
standard
and uh tomorrow i don't think
openmetrics will ever disappear
but also open telemetry comes that can
help you doing that
and then if you implement this
standards then you are more or less than
diagnostic
so it's not helping me
this thing
so why do you want to be vendor agnostic
when when you work with the vendor tool
and you use their sdk
or library that supports instrumentation
of application you basically get vendor
lock
um as with anything you need to evaluate
pros and cons
if you if you say i'm going to marry
this people
and we want to live happily hour ever
after then you probably have no problem
with
using vendor tools because they are
actually
pretty cool in terms of performance they
are optimized and they give you all the
possibilities of vendor tools
however as i mentioned here
not all the vendor library is open
source datavog for example is better
than others but like new relic library
i'm not sure if it's open source at
least 4.net i wasn't able to find
the repository um some vendors require
you to install things
everywhere that you run your application
like in doc container
or in your vms in order for
instrumentation to work
and um this is probably
not exactly the thing you want you want
your application to report to them but
you don't want to take a lot of
things that are associated with this to
the application
or to to the infrastructure basically
you want you want to take it into the
application but you don't really want to
have your instruction backed by that
and uh what i have seen of course when
they try to look to make things
easy and therefore they introduce a lot
of magic
we know things like gvm profiling clr
profiling
auto instrumentation the problem that he
did never know
really how it works unless you go to the
source could try to understand
sometimes it's really going and to to
trace too much
and impact performance your obligation
so basically i prefer to be in control
myself
yeah i think this i will struggle with
this
all the way
um for metrics and
i think the this is um there is only one
place
one only one standard that is kind of
widely accepted
this is the this is how we do it um
open metrics i need to move a little bit
so open metrics is uh
is born from promises open work is
tries to standardize from his format and
make it available like this is how you
do metrics
in fact as far as i know as per now
prometheus is the only thing and
the only difference you really get is
that for example datadog
renamed their support for prometheus to
open metrics
kind of claiming that uh really you
don't need prometheus for example
datadog can scrap
your kubernetes parts if you expose
openmatic endpoints so basically there
is no promises there involved at all so
it's just a format
um openmetrics aims to
handle protobuf protocols so deliver a
metrics in both protobuf
and text all the promises only sports
texts
but for now the text format is identical
so basically it's the same thing
i'm really sorry about the slide first
time i use this tool
and i probably never should do that
ah jesus christ
so um i probably need to switch back and
forth the slides so it doesn't freeze
anymore
promises is the um is the time service
database behind
but it's platorial components that work
together in order to deliver metrics for
you
so it contains primitive servers bunch
of client libraries
including most popular languages
push gateway and i'll tell a little bit
more about this and export this
um it also has the alert manager
so this is how promises looks
it's their their picture it's not mine
you could see grafana over there
um right here so
grafana is actually the visualization
tool and we will get to it
in a bit so why prometheus
prometheus is open source and free to
use uh
it's been widely used um like everywhere
everyone who starts with kubernetes get
promised
on board tools like rancher they use
promises
out of the box so they basically have
their own installation permissions for
kubernetes monitoring
it has a lot of stuff to do with
kubernetes predefined dashboards and
stuff like that
a lot of libraries that support
prometheus and there are a lot of
exporters that help you export metrics
from your instructor to permissions so
you can build dashboards and alerts for
infrastructure as well
it's not for your applications only and
promises were always like scrapping your
prods for metrics
if you specify special annotation in
your deployment file
and you get kind of metrics for you if
you expose them
uh now people move to promise operator
i'm not going to cover this in details
so now i need to step out of the slide
and just
[Music]
talk about what kind of metrics we have
openmetrics support
two primitive metrics which is count and
gauge and
two aggregation metrics history exam
summary
i would say i never use summary myself
but histograms are very
useful to catch the performance
counters are usually um
useful for seeing how our system sort of
accumulates how its system is being used
accommodatively so it only increments
and gorgeously just they can change
freely so it's usually like
cpu consumption memory usage queue size
and stuff like that so we use
in production first three the summary is
not that much different from histograms
just
calculates quantile like 95 percentile
in sliding window
so and you do it on the client although
for histogram you would
want quantiles as well but you do it on
the server in a query
means that you shift the load on the
server so
it's much cheaper to run histograms on
the client it's a behavior and server so
it depends on what you want
so
let's uh let me ask you a question so
how many
of you are using uh net
at all just shout out
right in the chat
yes yes okay at least one
okay so um i will oh
two okay so three oh fine cool that's
cool thank you very much
so because i i'm i'm more like um
i do 90 of my stuff on.net so it's more
comfortable
environment for me so i prepared some
examples using uh
c-sharp so this is how i do stuff with
with promises in in.net it's pretty easy
to do you basically get a package there
are several clients
i'm doing deliberately because i don't
want to phrase there are several clients
uh i personally use permissionsnet
because i find it very kind of
you know promises oriented and
then you can instrument your your parts
of your application
in this example i instrument http
endpoints
which is using middleware so basically
it has a
very simple middleware that runs um
all the requests you make to the to the
tutorial api and collect some metrics
so i think
it's almost we're almost there so this
was about
yes this this slide it wasn't about
adding metrics it's about
exposing metrics uh through http so
basically it needs to have
you need to have sdk to do that because
you need to have a web server that will
open some endpoints that's basically
slash metrics it's by default
and then when you do this
you instruct your application to collect
metrics this is example it's a simplex
example collect http metrics but you can
also collect
uh your custom examples so let me go
and show you stuff not talking
so i have this simple application in
front of me
and it contains three projects and i
will only show
the first one uh for the moment so
this is what i've done as i said um i
have
used http metrics here and i
use math metrics to expose them
so in addition to that i use some custom
metrics but
let me not touch it first and i will
just
show how it's done
um just what do you get in the uh
not the one i want to run
i need to run this one
so this is a simple web api it has one
one
one controller with several calls
several api calls and i'm going to use
the get
for now so this one this is a simple one
it doesn't go to any database it's
probably
known to you because when you create
http web api application
with web sdk and dot core you will get
it
out of the box so
and then i added swagger so i have these
three endpoints
and i'm going to try it out
now if you can if if i go to localhost
5000 which is the
metric endpoint you can see there are
quite a lot of metrics that already
produced these are cli metrics so
virtual memory cpu segments blah blah so
quite a lot of stuff already
without even engaging with the api so
here
if i start calling this api i will do
several calls
stated there and then i go to metrics
again
refresh what you see is this
so this is this is these are
this is for example the the gauge so it
just measures the number
um this is histogram so
histogram gives you quite a lot of
detail so it tells
this is a controller the weather focus
controller this is the action
and it distributes the measurements to a
bucket so how many schools
were completed within a certain time
period so
this is pretty meaningless but as soon
as you put it in prometheus and you put
graffana visualization on top of that
you will have a lot of sense from
from the metrics this is basically how
we do it if you wonder why this
controller is empty no action
this is when i call this particular page
so you can see that
one call has been made so if you refresh
it there will be two
and this is for the api so if i just go
here hold it again
refresh the page and it will be seven
calls in total
so this is very quite easy to do so to
start with metrics if you just want to
measure your apis it's pretty easy to do
so now
you can also collect custom metrics
promises net client allows you to create
custom metrics quite easily you can put
them in
static variables instead of class or you
want to
kind of keep them close to the to the
actual operation it's up to you
so what i usually do i create such
metrics for example
they all need to have a specific
specific name and metrics also have
labels
and this particular case i always prefer
to have a service name
up name label
because how else would you find out
which microservice you're actually
measuring because
all metric names are identical
especially http metrics
and this is a custom label for example
this is a collection name
and because i want to um
measure mongodb in this particular case
and let me
i will find it useful to keep a
collection name as a metric because if i
go to different collections i probably
get different
times and stuff like that and i want
really to measure those operations
so the next would be that you could
create a generic wrapper that's what i
usually do as well
so i create the wrapper for synchronous
calls and
you just give it delegates and you give
it a metric to
kind of measure requests and the next
thing you do
is give it a counter which is optional
so if you want to measure the number of
errors for example that occur in this
call in those 80 box calls you can
do that and you use normal stopwatch
so that's nothing special about it
so let's see and then you measure the
actual operation
so here i call the measure method of the
um this this thing that i just created
this this method uh this function
and i then give it a delegate which
executes the operation
and i give it two metrics so there's two
metrics that i created before
one is the um the histogram another one
is the counter
so i hope that the counter will stay low
because
error count i don't want any errors and
i want to measure the time
what what time it takes to execute those
operations so how my database is
performing for example if i forgot to
create an index
then my database will be slow and my
users will suffer and i definitely don't
want that
so you might also get
to use implicitly so this is a very
explicit call you just put it there
instead of calling database directly you
rub it in the measurement
function you can also use them basically
if you can hook to
your instructor like mongodb has several
hooks and
you can measure calls and provide
metrics out of the box
and it gives you some information in
those calls like collection named
database name that you can use for
metric labels
so now get back to the demo
uh over here in this application i also
have another controller
or another operation which is a post and
post
uh creates a new weather forecast
completely identical as before
but it puts it in a database so
this is a normal operation so there is
nothing
happening here i have no measurements so
i can just use it
over here just close this one and if i
do the post
find out excuse
execute i'll first refresh the metrics
again
so you can see that post starts to
appear so i have four calls but there is
nothing about my course to the database
so they're not being measured this is a
total time so you can see
that this um
it's pretty fast basically so it goes
pretty normally
um because everything runs in dock
container on my local machine and goes
directly to memory
um so but i want to
understand how my database is performing
so
in to do that i'm going to do the
following
so as you can see here i configure my
metrics
this is a static class it's preference
you can
decide to do it this way or other way
these are the buckets we kind of figured
it out
um how buckets need to look it's a
different buckets
than for example promisius net uses for
automatic instrumentation but we find
this one particularly useful
um so and then basically i have two
two metrics one is a histogram another
counter exactly what i showed in the
slide before
so how do i use that so when i go into
the controller
and i create regions i don't use regions
please don't use regions too
i just did it because i want to hide
things
from here before i get there
so now i uncommented it and i can
maybe delete it but i keep it so i
wrapped my call to database which is
exactly the same call as before
in the measurement function so now i run
it again
and if i go back of course if i refresh
it will be empty because i mean there
are no http metrics just normal
kind of clr metrics and the machine
metrics so what i'm going to do is i'm
going to give some posts
again good good good
several times let's see what metrics
deliver
so you can see these are database calls
and they come with my custom metrics up
name which is a trace trace
which i configured in the startup and
the collection is whether
and these are number of calls and which
bucket they belong to
so none of the calls
went to the lowest bucket because it is
still a database so there is some
io overhead that means that most of the
calls go from
0.25 and beyond and this is in seconds
i believe um so the number of calls
match so you can see the post it's six
calls and
these are calls to the database so they
can be measured separately
which is pretty useful so let's get back
to the slides and see what we actually
can do about it let me stop the app now
so integral part of
actually introducing
making sense of metrics is not just put
them in promises promises have some
visualization tools which are very very
weak
very sort of um basic it's it's
it can only serve a purpose to
understand if metrics are going in there
or not
is a default de facto tool to visualize
metrics
so um usually promises and refinery get
deployed together
and it also supports alerting so you can
configure certain metrics and set up
thresholds when you can say i want to
get an email a slack
channel alert or something else there
are a bunch of plugins for grafana
rafana doesn't only support promise as a
source
of data but this is one of the sources
you can work with
and the promising snap
project sort of cipher they have a side
project
that has a collection of dashboards and
this particular dashboard is basically
measuring http requests
so this is pretty useful this is
some cli metrics also here garbage
collector
memory location number of threads and
requests and flights
and the duration of http requests of
course you can start
splitting them out because you want to
know which applications you will tracing
which or measure which which controllers
you're most interested in and stuff like
stuff like that
so it gives you a lot of flexibility
the problem there of course comes when
you start to have hundreds of dashboards
so how would you do them
how you even see them i mean people have
tons of screens and stuff like that and
then you maybe start aggregating things
by the way in prometheus you can
aggregate histograms but you cannot
aggregate summaries
so aggregation of histograms might give
you some interest interesting
possibilities
so and besides
now
i strongly believe now that's where we
started
so we started with metrics
and um we
went further and we understood that
metrics are not enough and everyone were
talking about open tracings like open
tracing europe intuition there and
i didn't know what it is so we started
to look at it and
essentially we we implemented open uh
tracing in bunch of obligations and
we're pushing our developers to do more
so why um
operations are never executed outside of
the contacts so if you saw the http call
that i just made http call
also called a database so it might do
something else
it might do a call to another service it
might send a message and stuff like that
so how do you find out that those for
example two individual metrics actually
belong together
how do you find out how your
hcp call or message
handling a single message how long does
it take in total
because just running a consumer for that
message is not enough
sometimes it produces other messages it
goes beyond the boundary of this process
and you need to know a bit more so in
this case
you start thinking about how would have
heard the context on all those calls how
i can consolidate them together
how i let this context cross the
boundaries and get them
process of the process so i can work
with the microservices and
at the end i want to have some
correlation so i can actually
find out how they belong together and
how they work
as a system because we're not talking a
system as a specific service the system
is a combination of services sometimes
so contact is what's important so you
need to
to kind of move contacts further down in
the execution pipeline
and you need to correlate uh the calls
the operations and you need
sometimes to cross cross-product
boundaries if we talk about
microservices
and i probably know the trick now need
to move mouse yes
it could work all right so
um systems are complex and in this
particular case
this is a tree of execution so we got
http post it does some db read and then
it does some updates and put writes in
the database back
and publishes a message and the message
consumer reads from database and rise to
the database oops
so remote calls and messages can cross
boundaries of a single process and you
really want to combine them in a single
sort of picture
so open tracing what does it do open
tracing
is not a library open tracing is not an
application
open tracing is the api specification
for
distributed tracing it contains
or like the repository open tracing has
a lot of language specific libraries
vendors provides their own
implementation of open tracing or
shims to their own tracers to actually
for you to use open tracing api
and for them to translate these traces
to their own specific
infrastructure and there are a bunch of
contrib libraries for different pieces
like for mongodb
for rabbit mq whatever else and for
middleweights like
asp.net core web api or for example mass
transit as a messaging
instructor middleware so
4.net core for example there is open
tracing library
this implements the api the standard ad
open tracing defines
but it doesn't give you so basically
what you can do with this you can
collect traces
no you can't collect traces you can
create traces
and you can associate them within the
process but you cannot collect them
so there are wrappers for open tracing
for example elastic apm has one data
dock has one and probably others do as
well
and there are packages for asp.net core
mongodb sql server and so on
as a contribution libraries remove a
mask
so let's get to the terminology and i'm
getting out of the view so what is the
trace the trace is a whole distributed
operation goes from the initial call to
your system so basically this is where
your data or the call enters your system
and it might contain a number of digital
connected operations
which are called spams trace doesn't
exist as an entity
trace is represented by the trace id
it's basically the way to correlate
spans together and spawn is a physical
thing it represents a middle operation
and they are connected like they the
child i can have
a parent a span can have a child and
that's one can have a child and so on
and so on so they form a hierarchy
span has a piece of state so span is a
stateful object that actually exists
and drought you can attach things to
spawns
um there is all even a possibility
attached logs but i never encountered
any
well there is one i know that can
process logs that attach the spans but
for example datadog doesn't
mainly use something else for logging so
usually what you it the span state
must have operation name it also has
things like span time span
type but these are most links
it needs to have a pressure name and the
operation start and stop timestamps
because otherwise you can't measure
things
spans also spans they contain tags and
tags are used by
instructure sort of spam collectors
to visualize them and to be able to find
them to build sort them and stuff like
that
so and the context is the
implementation dependent state so it's
how different vendors implement
span state and most of the
implementations use trace id
and span id as the correlation that
defies and to build
sort of um the sequence or the tree
and the mileage items i don't know what
it means is actually baggage items this
title
uh so in tags as i said is just way to
kind of visualize them
so again so one choice consolidates one
of most bands which form a tree
and i use the ids like one one one is a
child of one one two the child
one and so on these are artificial
things although.net core diagnostics
activity or dotnet activity
thing or concept uses hierarchical id
similar to that this is just for
illustration purpose so you can see
in the parent and child relationship
but all the spans have the same chain id
they belong to the
same root span that started the whole
thing
so if it doesn't make sense i will still
i will show you really quickly how it
works in real life
but this is some pictures that i find
quite useful
and you can find down there where i
found them
so this is for example a whole picture
of executing
the um the operations so there is an
http
http call over here
so and then we start the first span this
is the first band then it goes to load
balancer
and then it goes to for example
authentication server authorization
service
and stuff like that so all these
individual operations
get their own spams and this all all
this spans form a trace
and if you look here over there
so you can see that this they use color
coding
so i can show you waving hands
so here they use this color to indicate
a whole span it's very inconvenient to
show because i don't
see what i'm pointing to this is the
whole span
and it it basically represents um
no here this guy so this is
uh you can see the colors um and they
match
so basically it was pretty very useless
for me waving hands because i don't know
where to point
so i have a better point here so
these these two are the same
they just when they put on the timeline
they make a lot more sense because we
know
the start and the end time stamp we know
how to visualize them
and the going from top to bottom
basically forms the hierarchy
so if we cross the process boundary
so the parent span it
ends in the service
that's initiated it and then the context
being
transformed to and put somewhere in the
metadata of your message or http call or
whatever and
with that call with this metadata it's
moved
what that that context actually gets
delivered together with your call
to another service and then it gets
extracted from the metadata
and on that site you say okay is there a
metadata for the parent span
yeah well look at that look at this i
have some metadata so let me
kind of recover the parent span in my
process
like it's existed from before and i
start my new span as a child of that
final span
so it's a bit confusing some at times
but if you start doing that you will
get it a bit quicker so but
to start using it it's not that hard
core to be honest
so
um what we need to do
is to
for example in this particular case i'm
using open tracing contrib.net core
which traces quite a lot of things
i just needs to register this in the i
container so it all gets
kind of wired together there is no magic
there though you can re
easily read the code and find out what's
going on
so the problem with that is that when i
do that
unlike metrics because metrics for
prometheus are pool based and i probably
should have mentioned this so promises
when it scraps your service
it will call the metric endpoint on its
own
and you can have other instructions like
datadog calling your service and
scrapping and metrics
traces are not like that nobody will
scrap traces you need to push traces to
the
so the default implementation the open
tracing library for
any language default tracer is no tracer
so
your your traces don't go anywhere so
what you're gonna do
is to attach it to send it to some place
so one of the tools that people start
playing around with uh when they
when it comes to
traces is jager jager is
the tool created by ubertech a long time
ago
just for that purpose and it embraces
open tracing from the start basically
it's built around
open tracing formats and stuff like that
um
it's pretty easy to run so you all you
need it
has a lot of components i think it
shovels data to cassandra and stuff
but uh you have one container it's
called all-in-one you can just start it
up and it will work
and uh but you know when you do yago
you're on your own you need to maintain
it
so let's just try using it
and see what happens so the demo again
i'm getting back to my application and
let me do
a little bit more so here in the startup
i have this thing that's called open
tracing
and this is this is jagger those three
lines are jager
this is how you register the
implementation of a tracer with open
tracing
and this is how you add open tracing
basically and
open tracing is not required to produce
your custom trace it's just tracing http
uh web api out of automatically stuff
like this
so but it's really not needed for
tracing something else so what i also
did
i used um manga tracing library
contribution library to trace
calls
so let's see how this works i have
another operation my controller
which is a post
um yes that's the one i use sorry it is
the same
so i don't do anything here unlike with
measurements
when i measured i had to wrap it in this
measure function call i won't do
anything at all
so what i'm going to do now is
to run this application
yes
now i go here and i'm going to visit
swagger ap um not swagger jager
jagger swagger and because it's cryptic
i kept it in the comments
so over here go to jager and this how it
looks
because i was running this app before i
have some
traces probably over here
yep but i will do some more
as you can see that i come i don't need
metrics anymore
it works with the post so i do some more
posts
and now i come here i do again
and there are more traces traces don't
come immediately there is
a bunch of work being done to batch them
and stuff like that
and sample them out as well so not all
traces actually reach your instructor
um let's basically get most of it
so if you can if i open one trace you
can see here that this is the http call
that i received and it took about
nine milliseconds as part of this call
uh it went to the controller so
basically probably there is some
sterilization work
some routing and stuff like that over
here
i called insert and this is where
i return the result
so it's very very useful to have it and
look at this
so if i click here i have a lot of stuff
that helped me to analyze what's going
on so i have a process
my machine stuff like that and i have
information about
the http call there is a log entry as
well
so it gets associated with logs no it's
not associated with logs it's basically
jagger connects to net core logging
in structure and put logs inside the
span as well
and here what i did i actually called
insert
and you can see quite a lot of things
are going on so this is the
statement this is the host name
it's the instance and stuff like that
and
the process information so a lot of
information can be
actually fetched from the span so and
it's up to you what you put in the spam
this is just the default stuff that the
contribution library puts in there
but you are free to put anything you
want so
as you can see uh it looks not that
scary as
on the slide so that's why i was eager
to show it to you
and it's very cool so let's get back
over here and i want
this is we are still in the same process
right so it's not that distributed
so let's make it distributed so what i
have i have another project
here and some other part that's hidden
what's hidden is configuration mass
transit mass transit is very popular
free open source measuring middleware
4.net
and i again use some contribution
library to do both
um open tracing and
collection of metrics metrics went to
the core
mass transit library that was originally
my package
and i gave it to chris now it's part of
the mastering itself and probably we
will create one for
west transit but this is good enough um
so the second application has exactly
the same configuration but it has an end
point the consumer of that message
that we're going to send and here's the
consumer
basically it makes it it doesn't absurd
of the very similar documents to another
collection
and another database so it's very simple
operation done in very similar way as um
as the controller itself but
in order to make it distributed i will
ignore the post controller
and i will use this one which creates
exactly the same object as before but
instead of putting
the database it publishes the message to
them to rub it in queue
so let me run this application
i have now two services running at the
same time
and i can look at their metrics
this is the one that is running it still
has all the collecting metrics because i
haven't stopped it
localhost 5001.
so this is completely empty because it
has no
no calls yet so let me use the
put thing and i can execute it
again several times i can look at
rabbit and q
they all run in docker on my machine in
docker compose
so you can see that there were some
messages coming over if i look at the
queues um
there is a history so there were
messaging coming through they all
consumed
so it's fine there are no errors over
here
so if i go to metrics of the first one
i can also see that the put controller
has been called
several times
and this is it for some reason i'm not
getting promisious metrics for mass
transit but that's not what i'm showing
that's okay here is the consumption
metric
so you can see that this is the message
type that i
was sending uh this is a consumer type
and this is how
it went to the bucket and this is the
service name which is trace remote
so it's already pretty useful i have
some metrics
[Music]
let me go to jager
search for traces again
and hope that there will be some
traces that are distributed it doesn't
happen immediately straight away
so i i sometimes need to wait
i swear to you that it actually went
through so i need maybe to refresh it
yeah so trace remote is coming to the
list of services now it wasn't there
before
this is how the command was executed so
this is how
spans in that service were built so i
receive
a message i call the consumer well mass
transit calls it for me and i do
update
but again it doesn't give me any
distribution right so something is
not exactly right so let me go over here
find traces again and i couldn't find
anything okay let it
just process things on its own and i can
do some more calls
and meanwhile while processing the
traces i can go over here
yes definitely doesn't have us hasn't
yet processed the traces
and i guess i would need to return back
to it a bit later
just to see how it went
or i can just try to find all the traces
that i had from before
now it has only recent traces so let's
wait a little bit
and get back to the slides and i come
back to the picture and show you
distributors
all right now
um i was going to show you this the
architecture
how they call it in in jager um
but it's not very kind of impressive
because it just has two services running
on my local machine
this is much more impressive this is a
picture of datadog
service map that kind of uses traces to
build this
diagram and it's very cool because uh
you can see all the stuff and you see
resources that loaded uh the most in
in red circles those that are green are
kind of fine
um and it has connections between them
so all the distributed operations
going across service boundaries or
reaching out to the database for example
here
you have uh the store there's probably a
web application
that has a an icon of web that goes to
represented the separate service
and it goes back and forth
and there is a product recommendation
service there is a queue in radius and
stuff like that and they all talk
together
and the size of the ball or the circle
identifies how how many requests the
service gets
it's really cool and in in if you look
at data dog in production you point into
one
thing you can zoom in and it will also
draw the lines
so it kind of indicates with dash dashed
arrow where requests are going to
and maybe we have time to show you the
production
and this is what's called flame graph
it's very similar to
just to to jager so datadog and other
or tracing providers or vendors they can
build this kind of graphs this one is
not really distributed as such i mean it
doesn't go
sort of this cold the initial call still
kind of lasts
until the end typically this for me is a
sign of some sort of distributed model
so there's a lot of rpc calls going
between services
and if you have more distributed
architecture with messaging we actually
this call will end
it doesn't represent the trace it
represents a single parent span
and then some calls will be added
afterwards so it goes
further and further and further and so
on so and that's pretty cool to see
now um
i want to since i touched
let me see if jager actually catched up
and it didn't i have no idea why
i have i swear to you i've seen it i
should have put in the slide
it was actually putting it in properly
in in
in a distributed trace it's a demo
effect so i'm sorry about this
you see it it doesn't connect it so if
if it would connect it
they will pop up here together on on the
system architecture diagram
connected so somehow it didn't work
but it actually works it should be so
something is apparently wrong maybe over
here i can see something yes there is a
warning
it says that invalid span id
skipping clocks yes so it couldn't find
a parent
some reason so maybe my spans were
sampled on the parent side
or something else has happened so we're
just gonna call it several times
more just in case and i get back to it
later on if i have time
all right
um so i mentioned open telemetry in the
title of the talk
so but i want to give you some overview
of what's going on at the moment
in observability space in terms of
initiatives that are open initiatives
so not really vendor specific so there
is open tracing that we covered
it only works with traces and
rudimentary logging open sensors
is the initiative that aimed to
cover metrics and traces and they say we
will implement logs
in the future but there is no future
open sensors open census
roots in google dapper product and there
have a paper about it you can
find it very easily on open sense
website
but they decided to merge with open
tracing
and form together an open telemetry
initiative
that will cover metrics traces and
potential logs
i'll get back to it as last open metrics
will survive definitely
promises is based on open metrics
basically this is promising standard
uh they only aim to make promises matrix
format the default one for metrics so
promises in grafana this
the speed combination think it will
continue to exist
it's not going anywhere but vendors
uh of clouds observability
kind of tools like datadog and neuralic
they start to adopt open metrics in
terms of like
they can receive it instead of
prometheus you don't need promises
anymore and they can build graphs for
you instead of using grafana
so it's up to you how to do that
um open zipkin is a bit weird thing
it's very very popular i have to admit
it it
was done to do distributed traces and
uh it's just a tool like jager is a tool
originally developed by uber attack
zipkin is a tool developed by twitter
so they say okay we open source it and
we form a community that's called open
zipkin
that will just provide libraries and
stuff like that instrumentation but
the only product that can consume zip
code traces
open zip code traces is zipkin so you
kind of stuck with it
but if you want to give it a go i mean
it's fine
uh it's it's a decent product and i
heard a lot of people using it
open telemetry is interesting based
as i said open tracing and open sensors
decided to go together and create a new
um specification for that will cover
kind of everything because you saw that
metrics are kind of isolated on their
own
choices are on their own but they
measure the same things and it kind of
makes no sense to do that
so when you measure
with when you create traces they have
start and stop right so you can
potentially build metrics from that
um so opencelebrate aims to solve
all these problems including the logs in
the future in addition to that
they have some more interesting things
in the pipeline
so open trade temperature isn't better
now and i'm going to talk about it
in a moment so
um orbit telemetry provides a single set
of apis libraries agents collect the
service the
with distributed traces and metrics from
your application
so most likely it is the future of
observability but it's a bit too early
to start jumping in this wagon i think
if you really want to have something in
production
you would be just as well very in a good
position
using open metrics and open uh
tracing so but what they do
is they created a specification for api
and also for sdk so they dictate how you
create libraries that support those apis
they have implementation for a bunch of
platforms you go to open telemetry
phones
quite a lot of already done but
unlike anyone else they also decided to
create their own protocol
it's based on jrpc and protobuf so it's
pretty performant
no one else except of zipkin actually
have done it
so standard protocol that will just work
as part of open telemetry they create
the collector it's written in go you can
find it over there
so it uses the protocol to basically you
can send data to the collector
and a bunch of exporters that are vendor
specific so you can export
stuff that you collect with open
telemetry to prometheus
jager zipkin whatever else
so let's touch some terminology of open
telemetry trace is basically
almost the same it's virtual and it's
represented by rsid a span is also very
similar to open tracing span
but it has a little bit more context and
more into the state so spanned context
is very similar to open tracing but it
must have trace id and span id
open tracing said it's vent
implementation specific
how you basically correlate
uh openclam just says you must use span
id and trace id to correlate
this is the way to go so to kind of
eliminate this confusion and correlation
context is similar to baggage items in
open tracing
but it also used in logs and metrics so
it's not only that the contacts is
attached to traces but attached to
everything
so the protocol is a unique thing in
open telemetry
so they aim to kind of define a standard
for how telemetry being delivered to the
instructor
a collector as i said a component that
receives the protocol
data funny enough it can be used as a
standalone tool
it's a case receive stuff but it also
can be used as a component as a library
so you can build your exporter
so for example datadog build
an exporter that uses a collector
component
to export data to their own instructor
so they use statsd for
metrics and they use their own protocol
for traces and so basically they receive
data
using the collector convert it over and
send it to their own instruction their
own format
there are a bunch of exporters i think
about 20 different
vendors you can look at in the repo find
out
so they have a bit different set of
metrics so they have counters up and
down counters
recorders observers they introduce a
concept
observers which is a synchronous metric
asynchronous metric is different
because with opencelebrator you don't
necessarily know unlike openmetrics
which
which is normally a pull so someone
calls you to collect metrics
with openclimate you don't know if you
use a collector it will actually be a
push model it means that there will be
significant overhead if you send all the
metrics every time you do
the operation so they introduce the
observer
for you in order to not sort of every
time update the value
but the observer can call your metric
and observe it at a time when it's being
collected
so it's kind of trying to solve this
push versus
pull model in in a nice way
uh and aggregations at this moment
complex aggregations aren't really
defined in the spec so i
quoted a very long line from their
documentation
they say we want to have it but to be
honest there is only one implementation
that i've seen that has
for example histograms is the
implementation of go which is the most
advanced one
all others that either have plans so the
most they have is a comment line they
want to have
histograms or none so for example.net
implementation or java implication has
no aggregation metrics whatsoever
which is a bummer so it's it's really
a big thing that needs to be done
so in.net since there are a bunch of
people saying there are dotnet
developers
so check out the repo basically there's
a small group of people working on that
i
was contributing as far as i can as much
as i can
but they might need help so there are
regular meetings
i never participate in any but if you
really want to get involved please do
it's basically the community effort it's
backed by
large organizations like this particular
one
is quite a lot of microsoft people are
working there
on the code but apparently the more
people get involved
the faster it will go it uses system
diagnostics
with the event listeners and activities
which activities are pretty new things
so if you haven't looked at that you
might want to do that as well
and the openslim24.net has already quite
a lot of instrumentation mainly it
goes around microsoft owned things so
contributions for things like mongodb
radius and stuff
i think they have sec exchange radius
instrumented because they actually use
it themselves
but for example there is nothing from
mongodb
but for those who use sql server it's
apparently there
and they have open tracing shim so if
you have your application instrumented
with open tracing open telemetry will be
just plug in if it's necessary or not
it's up to you to decide but it gives
you sort of migration path
so we're moving along for all
developers.net whatever
java python so
i would suggest use some of the open
source tools for open tracing and open
metrics
uh don't go with vendor locking unless
you're absolutely sure that they're
going to stay with this vendor for the
rest of your life
you will get a better knife nicely if
you don't do observable services yet
but you want to do services make them
observable from the start really i mean
i mean it
try helping open celebrity project
moving forward if you can and check
opens them to status regularly maybe it
will become other better soon
so it just out gathered to better stage
about the months ago
for net developers you would do the same
i mean
in addition you might want to consider
using system diagnostics activities and
stuff
because they have kind of things
obligation inside
diagnostics for for azure works with
with activities basically there is
almost nothing to do
and all microsoft libraries including in
the clr in http client
sql whatever they actually produce
diagnostics
events which you don't see
normally unless you attach diagnostic
diagnostic listener
it provides a lot of information about
how the application is running
you can create your own stuff uh there
are
a few places where you can find things
and i might just write some simple code
as well
to show how it's done we created a few
instrumentation libraries
using that it's pretty nice i mean it's
it uses sort of that core native things
to instrument libraries that you can
actually write
uh a sort of conversion to open tracing
and or open celebratory when they
you want to not touching the library
itself
um yes and now
it's question time
and so if you if you want to reach out
you can just go to twitter and i have
this
black screen and i completely forgot
about the nice things
about like this like this so
i'm popping up in front of the camera
again so you probably already forgot my
face
so here i am so if you want to ask some
questions i i saw a question in the
in the chat about the slides i already
exported them to pdf i will put them in
slack
in a room place and i probably put them
in slide deck
in in slideshare or something so if you
have more questions
it's time to ask if we have a little bit
of time